all right so let's jump in what is it
about nimona that like Drew you to the
project both the story and the character
um I mean so many things I think that
this is such a multi-faceted character
you know this is
um there's not a lot of opportunities as
an actor to display this many emotions
in every single scene and I think every
time I showed up into the booth it was
almost like solving a Rubik's Cube
puzzle of emotions of how to hit those
levels
when I need to hit them
um and it was exciting you know this is
a story that I think represents a lot of
things that I believe in
um and being able to do that in a way
that is so attainable and exciting and
silly and funny is a rare occurrence so
obviously this is based on a graphic
novel but did you get the chance to kind
of work with the creative team and
expand nimona beyond what existed on the
page definitely you know this was
created by Andy Stevenson I think as one
of his college thesis and then that grew
into a web comic and then from there
that grew into a graphic novel so you
know this is a a character that I think
is has shifted and changed you know
shifted like the character but she
shifted and changed in so many ways and
it's such a fluid character that
um you don't get to see often so being
able to kind of jump into that and and
and to play all those different kind of
intricacies and you know while all you
know all at once honoring the original
Source material was was hard and fun and
and yeah exciting pneumonia is a very
intricate character as you said um your
co-stars have talked about getting the
chance to kind of ad-lib a little bit
and I wonder if there was space for you
to do the same as intricate as she is
like was there room to play with that a
little bit yeah for sure I mean I think
that's what added to it you know the
Improv was an opportunity to kind of
expound on those little nuances you know
to to hit those levels you can't always
do what's on the page and you know Nick
and Troy just kind of prodded and pushed
us to go further and further and further
and Define those things and a whole lot
of that you know is not far off from me
as a person you know I I have a lot of
you know uh silliness to me and a lot of
kind of Gremlin energy that comes
through sometimes and being able to to
expound on that in the booth it's just
safe you know really supportive space
was
so fun to be honest if they're like a
specific ad-lib beat that you remember
being a favorite of yours oh my gosh I
don't know I mean there were there were
so many so many moments I think it was
all the moments of playing in the fight
sequence all those silly moments where
she's like he peed his face Auntie
peta's arm repeat his arm like there's
so many little if you listen to every
time I shape-shift there's like little
silly things we did throughout that
whole sequence which was chaotic and and
very funny so besides this this chaos
sequence we don't have to get into
spoilers but is there a moment you are
most excited for audiences to see
um
yeah I mean I think what audiences are
gonna be really surprised by is even
with how fun and silly this project is I
mean there's there's so much heart to it
and I think that's the thing that really
takes you by surprise is the chaos kind
of gets you so swept up in this tornado
but then when you're at the eye of the
storm and there's this silence to it
that
um you you know you really look Inward
and it's a really beautiful experience
um and I and I I love when people watch
it I'm like so wait like what did you
feel what did you connect to which
moment did you find was your moment that
you felt seen
um and that's so rare for a project it's
really rare for an animation film as
well and if you can speak a bit too
I guess the challenge of bringing that
heart out because like I said it does
have a ton of heart but when you are
performing voice only like were there
specific ways that you kind of worked to
bring that
to bring that out like what what is that
process
um in conveying the heart I think I
could really uh relate to you know
hiding your emotions with a lot of
bravado or you know what I mean show not
showing exactly how you're feeling in in
circumstances that you know you're
protecting yourself within
um and that was something that you know
when I'm doing that dialogue it's you
know because with with voice over you're
not memorizing lines you know so you're
reading it you know when they send it to
you which the scripts change as you
record them so you kind of get the pages
like three or four days before you
record
and you had those three or four days to
pour over the sides and to to figure out
how you're going to do it and then you
don't really say them out loud a lot
until you're in the booth doing the
moment so you don't find that
like sometimes it strikes you in ways
where there were moments where we were
doing scenes that I would tear up in
because
they're so full you know what I mean
um and again that's not something that
you usually have an animation where you
have that amount of vulnerability
um and I think it just speaks so much
for the writers and and for the source
material too that
I didn't have to overthink a lot of it I
just had to be and then you know
find those little beads it was really
fun so what do you hope that audiences
take away from the movie I hope that
audiences you know feel represented I
hope that they feel that you know
this is a story for anyone that's ever
felt different you know that's anyone
that's ever been villainized for being
themselves which we all have in some
facet at some point
and being able to to see that on screen
with a character that's
so
full of self-love that so full of
self-acceptance that's so confident and
just badass in the way that she
represents herself you don't usually get
that kind of you know that kind of
character that you just want to like
stand behind and stand beside and I
think that we can all use a little bit
of nimona in our lives